dos directores aclamados en cannes
regresan a la competencia por la palma
de oro
el ganador de la palma en 2017 el
director sueco rubén oslo un regreso al
actual set con su más reciente trabajo
triángulo of sun es una cinta
desopilante y cruel
[Música]
oslo un maestro del cinismo y del humor
ataque esta vez el mundo de la moda y de
los millonarios la gente podrida de
dinero y de superficialidad por su cinta
pasan influencer 'top model' oligarcas
rusos y empresarios que se ven obligados
a cambiar de jerarquías
y tú
por su parte el director rumano cristian
mungiu el ganador en 2007 en cannes por
4 meses 3 semanas y 2 días regresó a la
alfombra roja con rm n dispuesto a
llevarse otra palma de oro
[Música]
murió hace una radiografía de las
sociedades occidentales y su lote de
problemas a través de esta cinta filmada
en transilvania que cuenta la historia
de un padre y de un hijo quienes viven
en una comunidad donde reina el racismo
en rm n nos habla del lugar de rumanía
en la unión europea y de la mano de obra
extranjera en una cinta implacable y de
una gran factura estética
o exportar a rusia